[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
trade between our nation's last year was
almost 240 million dollars we see a
British companies employ a million I
think we use this figure for each
companies employed a million business
and every morning a million people okay
of course that's where a good bilateral
trade agreement but also I think
building a wider employment partnership
for the future as well and working
together influencing
chicken we believe in keeping markets
and I'm keeping all industries
businesses potential and I think the
refuge opportunities and challenges for
us to work together to tackle long as
well and the opportunity today so in a
few moments I will ask to vodka to a
small discussion but first of all I'd
like to ask you mr. president well thank
you very much friendly so appreciated I
very much appreciate the relationship
we've had is been outstanding and some
people know that some people don't but
when I know it but it's been really a
very good relationship and I appreciate
it very much
we are your largest partner you're all
are just what a lot of people don't know
that I was surprised they made that
saving yesterday a lot of people said
you know that but that's the way it has
been there's an opportunity I think a
great opportunity to greatly enlarge
that especially now in light of what's
happening to tremendously enlarge that
make it must be there's a pretty
relationship so we're gonna be working
on that today and move it a little bit
tomorrow and probably into the next
couple of weeks but I think we'll have a
very very substantial trade deal it'll
be a very fair deal and I think that
this is something that your folks want
to do my folks want to do and we want to
do and we're gonna get it done I just
like to congratulate you and having done
a fantastic job on behalf of the people
of the United States and it's an honor
to have worked with you and I don't know
exactly what your timing is but stick
around the food is the
[Music]